well as hundreds of thousands of
americans continue to claim unemployment
benefits
congress remains at a standstill over
the next corona virus relief bill
and you know yet again another potential
government showdown well that's looming
on december 11th kevin court live at the
white house
on whether or not this can be avoided
hey kevin
eric good to be with you you're right
negotiations on another covet 19 relief
bill
are at a standstill but here's the good
news that actually may be about to
change and certainly we're hoping that
will happen because i think all
americans and i certainly speak for my
family and i'm sure yours too
would love to see the people who need to
help get the help that they need
there are some measures that may be
attached to a spending bill
that must pass by december 11 to avert a
government shutdown
that actually may involve some possible
relief but
as federal health officials meet this
week to make crucial decisions about
who they'll give the green light to as
far as getting that coronavirus vaccine
out there first pressure is now again
mounting on congressional lawmakers to
step up and
strike a deal i'll tell you what would
really
make a difference here a big federal
stimulus
sooner than later with a lifeline to
small businesses
restaurants folks who are unemployed
that would be a game changer
not just in their lives and in their
prospects let's be clear what capitol
hill has been informed of
there's there's trouble ahead they need
to act now they can't wait
until millions more americans fall into
that chasm and won't be able to get out
peter navarro over at the white house
speaking there of course the president
has repeatedly chastised congressional
lawmakers
imploring them to get something done
house speaker nancy pelosi you may
recall turned down a
1.8 trillion offer by the gop in the
white house
but hope remains that relief will soon
be on the way eric yeah that is so many
of our fellow americans so desperately
need help as we all know
kevin thank you